Raim asalam alaikum Dr. Zakir Naik. Uh
good night. I uh I am Sabila and I'm a
college student in Bandung Islamic
University. I'm from communication
science major and according to the topic
tonight um the universal brotherhood. I
am curious and I would like to ask a
question about how is our best reaction
um for those people who have a wrong
sexual orientation in terms of Islamic
rules and without breaking the relation
between us because um sometimes if uh I
give them a lecture for the example I
don't want to make them hurting or
something like that so what is the best
approach for those especially like
friends who have a wrong sexual
orientation. Thank you.
>> Sister, may I know what do you mean by
wrong sexual orientation?
>> Um, it's like
>> are you talking about LGBT?
>> No. Uh, yeah. The LGBT
>> in a wrong sexual orientation.
>> Okay.
>> You talking about how should you talk to
friends who are lesbian?
>> Yes.
>> Or gay.
>> Or bisexual.
>> Yeah.
>> Or transexual.
>> Yeah. or I
>> wrong sexual orientation
sister in Islam we believe that human
beings have been made only into two
sexes male and female
we don't agree with this concept of
lesbian or gay
it's haram in Islam and Allah puts it as
a major sin sin number 11 sin
Yes. Nine. Sin number nine that
homosexuality and Allah gives the
example of Kuth
of Kuth that those people who who did
homosexuality Allah turned that town
upside down. So in Islam we believe that
there are two sexes male and female. And
we believe in heterosexuality
not homosexuality.
that man and woman Allah says in the
Quran in surah chapter 30:21 Allah has
created men and women and has put love
between their hearts
so this LGBT has just come recently it
was there some lesbian was there but now
it has become more previously it was not
allowed in almost all the countries in
the world now it is growing
so we have to do dawa to them
that if they have certain problems you
have to dawa to them and convince them
that this is against nature.
Unfortunately there are many groups
which are supporting them and now we
have started rainbow color but in Islam
we believe that there only two sexes
male and female. Allah made two
successes because of various problems.
Now they of all the fitna the haram
activity that people do they start
thinking out a girl wants to become a
boy wants to become a girl. This is not
accepted in Islam.
So we have to convince them ask them to
read the Quran
and ask them to come to the h and
convince them that this is it is
unnatural.
Naturally, a man remains a man, a boy, a
male remains a male and a female remains
a female. Hope that answers the
questions.
>> Thank you.